[Music]
so
hello how are you
fine thank you no no no no
here we go we're back welcome back
everyone
part three baby plowing through this bad
boy
i like it more and more oh god my whole
window was resized a lot
i think stuff like ethan's hand getting
[ __ ]
up is just so funny i like how they're
not taking it seriously
i was looking through that part again
where his hand gets chucked off and even
his [ __ ]
sleeve gets healed like the jacket
sleeve
i don't know it's great okay now i gotta
remember what we were doing
um we were going to the house with the
red chimney
and i think we went there already right
hold up i gotta re-acquaint myself i
should have done this before
we have yes we have us oh yeah we killed
the pig
chat just kept kept telling me kill the
pig kill the pig and i was like
no i can't do that that's terrible
but they made me do it right over here
okay
i kind of don't remember we're supposed
to go here here was a puzzle
uh-huh
and then we went through here what did
we get
out of all that that's why i'm confused
we didn't really get anything
i should make one of these
or two apparently oh god we should make
we can make so much stuff i didn't even
realize
we're rich
look at us stacked boys
let's try that
let me retrace my steps then because
then i i know
we're doing there's bedding up here and
we're supposed to go down here
and there's all the goats but we are
looking for the house with the red
chimney which is this one which is at
the end of the road
the end of the road that doesn't exist
okay
we got monsters yeah
oh let's kill him with this knife
that was a headshot what are you talking
about
all right let's take it easy
come on come on
i'm not wasting a bunch of crap on
shitty vampires
[ __ ] you okay
so this is it i don't know how we walked
in circles
oh my gosh it's so hard to play a horror
game with studio lights in your face
it's like
hey we got bomb
how are we doing how's everyone doing
today
right it's locked from the other side is
that
possibly the house for the red chimney
i want the loot from the guy i shot on
top of that
come on oh there it is chem flute
got him oh that looks like a big boy
hold on present for you
i got all the gifts come here
[Laughter]
oh god here another one [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you gotta walk on it bro
how are you still alive
tough guy okay i don't like this guy
anymore we used to be cool you and i you
know that
[Applause]
oh my god you have to hunch over
why are you so tough
thank you two landmines
on you [ __ ] you
big boy he had the knuckles from hades i
want those
oh i thought i only had once okay i
should have sniped him
we're using way too much ammo here i
don't like it
check the toilet always always the good
stuff in the toilet remember that
kiddos
okay we're definitely going in here let
me just look around first
ah a note locked due to missing
homeowner
it's annoying because i rebinded it
well not anymore
should we check this out first or should
we check maybe i'll unlock this really
quick
it's a winky no what is that
oh it says
i can look at pictures and say hey that
looks the same
i know i'm incredible oh
box out in a tight corridor you can only
mean one thing
huzzah
finally look forever for that [ __ ]
care how many times to set it up
i'm always gonna check it no matter what
isn't it weird in games how like made
one more other pot right you know that
right
you [ __ ] up
you know it capcom
all right we got some extra loot and the
wheel
very good
check the toilet always gotta check the
toilet
lock pick nice
so far we haven't run out of this which
i'm happy about
okay this house is spoopy
to whom it may concern due to luthier's
long absence i'm keeping a hold of the
his house key please find me if you need
it in regards to joseph
simmons simon benevientos
gardener beneviento
that doesn't sound very romanian
uh-huh i don't know where he lives in
the gardening house
isn't that what they do rich people have
a house for their gardener
is this the gardener's house
hello
oh i knew you were there and here we are
ow that must hurt whoa he just [ __ ]
turn don't do that benefient though
venomia no i'm not gonna die from a
garden there [ __ ] up all right you know
what beniviento
you can suck my
oh god you're pissing me out you're
pissing me
i knew i had him on that last shot that
was easy
oh i can wear a dress
or not okay so maybe that's one of those
items you guys are telling me about
that you can combine and if you combine
it you can sell it for more
sure seems like it
all right what do we got here more crabs
where do we go then
oh we have the wheel now then we should
probably go back and check that out
right
i don't like this area very much it's
cool though
i just hate these [ __ ] zombies
they're so irritating
and the wheel is over here
yo they have silos in romania [ __ ]
and then it's down here right nice i
remember
this better [ __ ] go this better go or
else we're gonna have a problem
thank god what do we got
what do we got that's it a lockpick [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here
did we check this problem
yeah okay i need to start thinking here
there's more wells okay cool they're
marked on the map at least
uh closest one why is our chicken on the
[ __ ] map
can we cut through here let's see if we
can cut through there
yeah we can
we cannot [ __ ]
i think i think i automatically picked
up the wheel uh
okay well let's go down all this road
and then to the right
or can we cut through here
i think we can yeah
i'm worried i'm gonna get jumped while i
do this backtracking
and then that gate is locked that's not
good
oh we can unlock it from here oh sweet
shortcut
and then we should have a well
right next look there's a [ __ ] pot
again
well where where where where where will
will
gotta find the chicken oh
wow wait didn't we find a body before
hold up
did i dream that
oh yeah we did so now we can combine
them
and it becomes rich
nice
okay there's more wells
i don't see why not let's go to fallow
fox
that's what that's called
we cleared out all these areas anyway
yeah
where the [ __ ] did i find the well oh
it's there
every romanian have that pot that's good
to know
that's a dead end
how do i get there i can go in there and
then through okay
shoot the game on the maiden shield is
that a okay
i'll try that is there one i've been
seeing these
and i thought it was a glitch no way
that's a gem
a gem ah
what thanks
okay i i thought it was a glitch last
time remember
[ __ ] it's like why is i
wait that's that looks weird that's not
supposed to be there
okay so we're gonna cut through here
what is that save point we might as well
save here and then
someone set up a computer here what the
[ __ ] operation date
uh nh all right let's say
no sign of evie or rb infiltrated
village
engage with a number of bioweapons find
evidence of our rv's location unknown
established based in church
quite the base
[ __ ] i was here hours ago
first time i played it oh [ __ ]
there's definitely zombies in here i
just don't oh it's gross
we're good definitely take this guy out
oh that's a tricky shot dude
don't alert them
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
oh you made me waste a sniper you happy
happy about this
shot you in the leg [ __ ]
finish him off get his [ __ ] legs oh
nice oh
hold up are we lagging
my internet my internet keeps cutting
off it's so
frustrating i hate it i don't know if
it's
my ethernet cable it might be my
ethernet cable i'm being a little
paranoid about it because
it gets stuck in the closet it's hard to
explain but
so i open the closet
and here we go
yes where was i
there's a crate over here
oh are you making noise
yeah i'm really i'm really sorry about
the internet situation i i'm very
annoyed by it
another crane
you guys have made me so [ __ ] anal
about looking everywhere
i was not normally like this in video
games i was like i plowed through it
[ __ ] it
but now i kind of enjoy it like oh i
found some flower guys
maybe we can use this later for the
secret ending
[ __ ] that's all right that's all right
it's all right guys shoot these right
before they attack you
ah [ __ ] you rooney how am i missing
point blank range [ __ ] you're so
annoying
i had you and then you came oh russ is
right
all right i'm done i'm done no rooney
give me my lay you [ __ ] date
just let me know if he likes because
then i'll just pause and wait for it to
reconnect
turn off aim acceleration yeah honestly
there is something so weird about it
i put it on weak but it's still very
irritating honestly
oh money
all right we how many birds did we kill
i don't know how i'm gonna find all that
[ __ ] in here
yeah this feels better already honestly
aim acceleration
yeah if there's something here i don't
know we're gonna find it
oh more flour nice
you just gotta look everywhere it's so
worth it
now why would i do that
no you'll you'll know if it's lagging
the whole stream will shut down
i know you people will tell me anyway if
you're lagging a little bit that's you
not me okay maybe i'm taking a bit too
long here i don't know
i just want to make sure i look
everywhere
and look everywhere twice apparently
okay i got pillows
luzia's next
i'll take it okay i'll load this entire
romanian village if i have to
explosive rounds what is that for the
shotgun or the sniper
that looks like for the shotgun
grenade launcher hell yeah
yeah give me
maybe i need to visit romania [ __ ]
what'd i just pick up another pig
come here give me a baby come on baby
i'll save you i'll save you
i'll save you just like the race
don't worry i'll save you
now lock this
we got to save this peg
i'm here to save your life
don't worry pig
give me all your [ __ ] no pig oh this
pig is porous
[ __ ] okay this feels like a thing where
as soon as i jump over something left no
all right are we cool we're cold pig
oh i told you to be cool i told you to
be cool
he's got rabies i have to put him down i
have to put him down now
hey don't attack me oh no
oh and it's my nightmare where i try to
mercy kill and it gets worse
mercy kill mercy kill mercy kill mercy
kill
ow mercy kill mercy kill it i'm so sorry
i'm so
suffering please i was trying to save
you from pain and now it's all worse
this is my worst i'm so sorry
why would you die just die i'm sorry
i'm so so quality oh nice
hell yeah follow me
vegans you didn't see nothing all right
oh pipe bomb rich pig i knew you were
holding out on me
i don't know why i do that i
legit have had nightmares of trying to
mercy kill animals and then things get
worse
that's just my worst scenario in my head
oh it's suffering we better put it down
oh god it's so much worse than that
oh it doesn't feel good why is this
color
rare ingredient gathered from pure white
pig what the [ __ ] a racist
resident i can't believe
if we go all this way just for let's
just say point in the building
hold up but we can't enter it can we
it's locked there
oh this is the oh this is a
the girl's house i remember now
let's see where she hides in the toilet
okay
okay we're we're literally just
scavenging for loot at this point we
should check out the chickens
for sure that's gonna be epic uh we got
that
we got some weird treasure i don't know
why
another save point in the church we know
that um
maybe go back to the merchant there's a
ladder there
that's probably where i need to go okay
making my way downtown
we load this city
oh did i seriously miss this
is that not on the map am i blind
no that's not
necklace another necklace
am i playing too slow now i feel like
it's worth it we're getting a [ __ ] ton
of stuff
oh baby oh
so here's what's to come the weird
puppet thing
dark souls boss and
blob and then probably some final boss
right
all right let's check out the chickens
i'm very excited for the chickens
let's not miss the chickens they're the
highlight of this
where the [ __ ] did the chickens go
a beast i miss the chickens how do i get
there
they're up here
ah thank you slushy 500 for mommy
milkers jesus christ
thank you that's how much mommy milkers
are worth
oh god we gotta go back
ethan needs a snack
i'll slushy on some mommy milkers if you
know what i'll get outside
how do i keep walking
chickens chickens i found you
now there's no romanians left to take
care of you
so i'm gonna have to mercy kill again
trust me
this pains me more than it pains you
don't worry chickens
don't worry chickens you'll go to heaven
no go to head chicken heaven
i'm sure that exists hey hey
mercy kill you're welcome vegans
welcome that was awesome
glad we checked out the chickens
that was definitely worth it smash like
on this video if you enjoyed that bit
now for the last [ __ ] time we're
going back okay
f's in the chat for the chickens and all
the pigs that had to be sacrificed it
wasn't my fault
it just sort of happened
now for the last time we go into the
ladder
how do i get there we have to go
can i even go there uh we can go here
okay so i have to go here
i have to make our left coming up
was this the left no
it's down here but this road is blocked
confused
i have to go all the way around aren't i
oh my god was i supposed to go where the
chickens were no
that's impossible
this game is so [ __ ] disorienting um
what
no this is open
it was always though
oh my gosh this place is a maze
can i cut through a window or something
oh we have cable wall another clue
we are stacked on items
holy [ __ ]
oh oh sink guys look it's your favorite
part of the game to sink
there you go
wasn't that exciting
still not entirely sure where i'm
supposed
this looks like a dead end to me
oh here we go here we go here we go
it's not really obvious on the map but
you can cut through there okay so then
we go
right through the tractor where we were
like six years ago
and then we go right and then we go left
and then we go up and then we go down
and then we go bing bong
here we go
sorry but where's the ladder
there's the last holy [ __ ] did i miss
that
red chimney house we're coming for you
oh progress at last another chicken
we have to mercy kill them
but all in due time
are we supposed to jump down here yeah i
think so
the chicken are a distraction the
zombies down here i know it
but i will have to do
give it to me just give me your [ __ ]
if it's any consolation i don't feel
good about it either okay
another ladder
they're just gonna they're gonna freeze
to that that's worse right
not my fault that they're so dumb okay
zombie in here
okay so now we can cut through here nice
barrows
the chickens just have a cross on them
now
rip can we open this on the inside we
can also
cut through here now hey hooray only i
did that earlier
uh okay ladder again now we can finally
enter
the red chimney house my car that was a
voyage what's the name
oh there's a cable here oh it's us
they want you to follow the cable but in
reality you're supposed to do this
three times and then that unlocks
no i'm not doing that all right
[ __ ]
can you sneak in this game
don't shoot me don't shoot me
you really just hit me one more time
baby
when you were already dead
that's [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was he eating romanians ah
or should i say romanians get it all
right
sorry romanians
i don't feel good about that one to be
honest
oh wow the wind key is just a single
piece
three more parts are needed to make it
whole
yes wow thank you
do we need that thing oh
we got it in here wow
so cool
i did it guys damn it
better see the sacrifice two ghosts to
mother miranda
offered wool to mother miranda
huh she wanted drugs if the livestock
won't stop the ruckus
that's why you should mercy kill the
livestock i was instructed to take the
atoms to the cave church
at sunrise but what i saw was prideful
the great four lords were there and
mother miranda was holding a child
she whispered something and touched the
child excuse me mother miranda
she never touched me so that's
inappropriate okay i can't explain it
well but the child turned into a white
crystal
then then she i couldn't help but speak
up and i asked her why she did such a
thing
mother miranda just smiled at me this is
the chosen child
she will return to her original form no
matter what befalls her
then she gave each lord a part of the
crystal in a flask and they left
i forgot to bow to mother miranda before
i fled i'm still shaking
what did she do what is that child the
duke again
damn damn son
yo that looks fresh dude i'll have some
bread give me that
oh guys there's a sink
your favorite part of the game see this
is what happens
people think there's something in the
sink but it's literally just telling me
to close it
hey it's pot again
yeah our daughter is dead she's [ __ ]
done
yes okay so that means we're done here
actually
means we can head on back head on back
that bothers me a little bit
how's it locked anyway
okay shopping time
how was it did you learn anything not
really
i found these feathers now tell me how
to fix this like you said you would
settle down first you must use that key
and collect
all of your little roses flasks
where are the rest of them there are
four in total
you have the one and the other lords
have the rest
lords
damn you know people saying mother
mirandas think but the cold
calculating ruler of this village four
lords serve unto her the first you've
already met
the lady demetrius oh [ __ ] i thought she
was mother miranda
the second lives deep in a valley of
mist the doll maker donna beneviento
none of her playmates have ever come
back from that dangled
state maybe because it's really fun dank
epic the third is moreau
a being of twisted flesh that lives in
the reservoir past the windmills
it is said that he is not the only
monster that lives in those waters
the fourth and most dangerous is
heisenberg
he works in his factory on the village
outskirts yeah he's definitely nice
and the project let's just say parts of
the human imagination are better left
alone
[Music]
[ __ ]
slushie gaming's girlfriend also says
mother male cares
what a couple thank you so much 500
again god damn
if you truly wish to save your daughter
you must first gather the four
flasks we got one do you a personal
favor
i've marked the lord's locations on your
map thank you
time sir some treasures still work in
this village
i'm sure each one will prove of great
use to you
why are you doing all this why it's all
part of our first class customer service
i mean he's not wrong these do come
again soon
we got 500 for each milker now god damn
as you wish
ah yes i have you what some quality
ingredients
bring them to me okay what is this so if
we bring him
oh you can make recipes these are local
romanian dishes
the bird and beast pilaf ooh
wow chorba de porque
it's a pork stew
ah very good wow you need a lot huh
we only have juicy game
now wait i'm sorry what
how many do we have do i have four
poultry should we make bird and beast
pilaf
carry on no i don't i can
hardly wait just excuse me a moment
he's gonna cook us up a burden feast
pilar
he's also a chef i mean he's for the
weight here's your share
thank you wow
damage taken when guarding has decreased
permanently
so you're really supposed to kill them
because you get a lot of stuff
wow okay let's try more
uh okay i think that's all we have
yeah oh
maybe now we need fish we should have
killed the fishes back in the castle
dammit i didn't think of that
what just happened
oh my game is lagging now
okay now it's better i'm so mad i didn't
kill the fish
okay uh anyhow
we have this wouldn't go
18 000. hell yeah splendid
do you know it's worth well you just
sold it perfect crystal skull
very valuable
uh let's see if we can combine any of
this stuff
do let me know if you find anything else
of value
indeed it is
uh huh could probably sell at
value
[Music]
hmm
um so i need
storage at this point my god but hold up
can i combine any of these doesn't look
like it
something could fit in the depression
oh maybe i can put the jewel in it
it's not giving me the option to
no two holes
i don't think this would fit in it i
guess not
oh good i was just thinking of ways to
pass the tide
i think i will sell this
that's barely worth anything and i'll
keep the crystal wing
i'll keep the necklace and the body
and then i think we need to upgrade
what is that i'm skilled at all sorts of
weapons modifications and we'll do them
for a small fee
upgrade our gun probably one moment
please
should i sell my other gun then
leave this to me
hmm this is all an investment ethan
this is clearly a better gun
there's 150 this is 170 already
i could keep upgrading this though
can i remove my upgrades from
this is tricky i want to make the wrong
decisions here
[Music]
but
yeah this is already quicker fire
worry not you can buy it back if you
like thank you
for to double the price eat [ __ ] dude
scope would be really good
looking forward to testing it out
food is life
hmm no
god created man's back to carry burdens
but to think you want to pile on even
more
greatly increases rate of fire
i can't afford the cheeky we'll do that
next i'll save the rest of the money
till next we meet
magnum ammo oh my god we're going to get
a
better gun are you serious
[Music]
so
[ __ ] it so did you say this way which
one is next then
is it the puppeteer
i look forward to this
very good very creepy
got some dead people here nice
oh no they're just puppets don't worry
gamers
oh geez i don't like this very much
okay doing fantastic there's definitely
gonna be monsters coming out very soon
all right left or right oh le du la dove
king kill on a cough
cough blonde and pink bunny holy dude
this way gamers
my release no
it's romanian magic
i knew it what's all this then
it's a bloody dead in
[Music]
okay
oh someone left their trolley here
oh maybe we can get some fishes back
here
should we go back and fish
hello babies
what was that horror game i played ages
ago with a bunch of puppets that was
really creepy i don't like clapping
try to kill the birds ooh does he like
bird me
sorry crows
you're gonna have to wait am i
am i locked in now
i'm locked in the bush is closed
it'll hold it'll hold
it hold it hold
see i just gotta say it incompetent oh
thanks
you were supposed to be dead kill her
kill her ethan
come with me there's something i have to
tell you mia
oh gee better follow
shoot a goat on the right side of the
bridge she
or real i wish you told me to five
seconds ago
oh spoopy
spoopy rose feels
different okay i don't care ethan you
have to fix her uh
we can dip her in the sauce like i
wanted to but you didn't
say it's safe for a child
yeah well because you're kind of
annoying i'm kind of
trying to be real be around no one likes
you
and that probably has something to do
with it you know you got to look at
yourself and not
what's wrong with others all the time
thank you oh this is shiny hello
beneviento ah very good
freed from the binds of flesh she now
walks the valley of
beverly cool good for her
literally no one asked yeah
knock knock
let's put uh let's put this
no [ __ ] way
what's going on
all right that worked
she fell for the old photograph in the
mirror trick
bet she thought it was a christmas card
dumb [ __ ]
ding ding
uh up
finally gotten rid of it yeah
it's hating having that in my inventory
oh no
come with me okay all right if you're
going up we can go together
oh maybe there's fishes here
damn it oh maybe this fishes
whoa that looks so sick
that's really cool
it is the christmas season
that's gonna be so annoying having that
waterfall next to your house that's so
loud
all right who in the right mind would
build a house here
it's pretty though i'll give them that
barrel
i thought i know you're not you got me
you're gonna die
sorry goat but i'm the goat
that's very soothing in a way
hey hey hey hey hello it's me
hello how are you
okay
let's do a quick scanner rooney that
can't go there because there's
apples in the way
[ __ ] this joint up
i have to i just have to
okay there's a string that goes to his
puppet thing
oh wait a check here
there's literally nothing in here come
on
dang it oh my god
she well well well
what's with people and creepy dolls just
stop it
all right you're making everything bad
for everyone just stop with your
demoning creations no one wants to see
them
you hear me well there's really only one
way to go
all right whatever reading the decline
and
fall of the demon king yes that's a good
one
was there something here no
what the [ __ ] there's nothing in this
place
can we go out
this place sucks
now march just creations are wonderful
how dare you think that's what i meant
uh what
okay what am i missing here
now there has to be something here
versus one of those where they want you
to look and then you go down and then
something is triggered
all right let's just see if we're going
down we'll change anything that's a tiny
painting it's so small
okay i guess we didn't did we check here
no we didn't okay
there's no loot and i'm so mad about it
if there's no alert there's no enemies
right
uh what look
a flower a banana flower
thanks for nothing
[ __ ]
anyone here anyone here hello this place
sucks
closet nothing's in it
all right i'm gonna speedrun this
because there's no load no man
bring it
let me kill something please
kill this chair if i have to
my god alkaloids are mountainous plants
there's something about plants for this
guy
but what does it mean
okay i don't get this part at all it's
super lame this is a bunch of how many
furnitures can you fit in a house dude
okay creepy corridor
okay ah at last
hey how you doing give me that it's mine
[Music]
[Applause]
just play along with kids they're so
dumb
wait where's my gun no they took my
[ __ ] gun
why why am i doing this what the [ __ ]
am i checking for a pulse
oh yes oh removed
silver key whoopee doopy
[Music]
daddy
i just got pickpocketed the [ __ ] out
sink guys look it's a sink and there's
water
but you love that don't you [ __ ]
waitings
okay so in this puzzle what you need to
do
get the water running so they think
you're taking a leak
but in reality
oh good she's done is this a dollar
yeah i think we got that okay let's look
at the mao
wanna open wide
um
her oh yes
uh-huh some only had a knife
that's a lot of stuff to examine
got it
examine her thighs
and there's another key
oh are we lagging
refresh gamers tell people to refresh
sorry about that
sorry about what there's nothing
[Music]
uh
maybe we can combine
we're just doing puzzle [ __ ] it's lame
as hell i don't like it
okay is there something we can wind up
with that key that we just got
probably a doll or something right
[Music]
hmm
of course yeah we can watch the blood
covered key yeah
that'll do
these things are useful i've been
telling you guys this whole time
what is it making out it's a wedding
ring
still don't care but okay it's got a
diamond
there are 5 29 11.
okay
hmm
no
[Music]
oh right maybe we can grab now the thing
in the mouth
with the winding key
nope all right i don't know
i don't know if i thought that would
actually work
oh wait
what was it sir 5 29 11.
yay for free
bye
[Music]
bye oh
you want me to come in a little visit
i'm good
fine let's check that i'll play along
with your little games
it has to be a doll somewhere there we
go
a moment of my time with ethan but this
music box box no longer plays
oh if only someone can wind it up
why is this here yeah
oops clicked the wrong
i don't know the cylinders the [ __ ]
sounds good
something's not right
okay so swap cylinders
oh i look at the scratches of course
so the first two seem alright
and the third one is wrong no no no
no i played it sorry
[Music]
i clicked the wrong button swap
cylinders x
okay that looks right
that looks right okay
so smart so very smart
[Music]
beautiful hey we can get
the thing out of her mouth this is so
convenient
love it
let's see what it said at the exit
excuse me door
uh i thought i saw something
okay i guess we need the key huh
that looks so real the text is so small
like it
more stuff in here huh our happy family
rosa's best friend in the whole wide web
she really likes this fairy tale the
most important thing
in the world to us a wedding gift from
grandma proof of ethan's everlasting
love so these are all the things
they collected okay
okay so the third one was what the most
important thing in the world to us
no i don't want to examine that i need
the photos
all right this is probably later once oh
yeah the photo was in the mouth wasn't
it
okay we'll come back here then
easy easy
hey baby what you got in here my big
okay tweezer yes
oh got you now wow
so spooky
oh hello how are you
uh which room was it no it wasn't here
it was by the entrance
all right put the film
oh we gotta rearrange them ugh okay
uh rosa's best friend in the whole wide
world best friend that's
me
how do i select that
uh-huh and then she really likes his
fairy tale uh-huh okay
all right yeah okay
the best thing ever is yeah wedding gift
from grandma
i didn't give him grandma and proof yeah
i think this is it
[ __ ] you game
oh proof of ethnos everlasting love my
bad
oh so scary
very ring vibes i like this
okay there's a well and inside the well
it's a long-haired girl that's super
screwed what
this didn't help at all
no oh yes
okay we're through the walls hello dolls
oh thank you thank you for the scissors
just cut those open with scissors
nail that puzzle hello dolls how are we
today
i'm gonna burn this place down when i'm
done with it i hope you understand this
let's call the police the romanian
police
yeah um i gotta say it's really cool
what they did with the resident evil
series oh there we go
i wish they'd brought back silent hill
like they did with resident evil
that's like the missing piece in
survival
this family well you horror yeah what
are you talking about it's too late
so much don't care i had to
i had to do it
[ __ ] i lost my pinky finger okay you're
gonna have to do better than that
have you seen my hands
have you seen my [ __ ] head
looks like something could fit in the
depression
um no the wedding ring we already
now we gotta hold on to the wedding ring
forever
hello close it oh we're here now
uh maybe something changed with the doll
hmm
let me fall down
ah this was not here before
spoopy okay
if we looked on the arm
um that was a symbol i don't know if you
guys saw it because i was lagging at
just that moment
it's closed so we don't know
oh right we can cut the bandages now
because we have the scissor
cut cut
look away kids
wow
so that's what's inside
it was this crow wasn't it or was it
this one
let's see how my photographic memory
serves to me
this one was closed yeah
i thought that was it i really thought
that was it
okay maybe it was a one crow
there we go yes
oh creepy
i like bass
oh i love this so creepy yes
oh this is sick
spoopy yes
this reminds me when you walk down the
ladder in uh
the seven one hey we got it
you just dumped some down here
don't care don't care don't care
fake baby i can tell a real baby from a
fake one that's a fake baby
i'm leaving [ __ ] you
bye fake baby don't care
alright so the exit should be right
about here
we made it gamers that was easy
if you ever in a haunted joint
oh that's creepy what the [ __ ] are you
all right i guess i'll go this way god
damn it
hey do you have a map because i'm kind
of i kind of
oh yeah i can cut that's right i can cut
through
here right yeah i remember the layout
i know this [ __ ] would happen
that's locked
i need the baby okay that's fine
we'll find the baby hey
creepy dolls how are you
okay very dark in here
there it is found it nice
is there a baby in here there is
excellent
is there more
okay we gotta go back there's a fuse
okay
creepy [ __ ] children man
[Applause]
[Music]
are you in there little one
don't kill me now
i'm swedish you can't kill me you'll
hear from the authorities
the council of sweden
oh nice okay
if i was a fuse where would i be hiding
in the brassica
in the sink of course
well i don't know
it's too quiet this looks very like
scandinavian but i guess it's romanian
yes oh
we got a flashlight nice okay we just
gotta make it out
no problem we've
we've gone through worse things my dude
okay we gotta we gotta we gotta trick
the baby
trick the baby into
um i don't really know
babies are smart
ah under the bed of course
i mean babies are very dumb i'm way
smarter than a child
oh whoa it's a big baby big old
slimeroony
[ __ ] you baby cut his toast
don't write me out [ __ ]
[Music]
run for it [ __ ] you baby [ __ ] your slime
child
so dumb you fell for the all the
strength of the book you idiot
if you weren't such a dumb baby maybe
you were gonna guide me
[ __ ] you chat like you
now it's kind of dark i don't know if i
remember the way ah here we go
nice stupid child
so dumb
okay now he came here last time
but not this time not this time
[ __ ] [ __ ] jab
yeah click the thing click the thing
click the thing and don't look back
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] come on elevator
come on what you got
[ __ ] you child [ __ ] you
[Music]
what is wrong with me
escaping so large
nice
now there's more all right i guess we
gotta kill the thing
hey i meant your baby i didn't like
it
oh hey what's up
[Music]
huh don't leave i can't let you
oh you're still alive
try and
oh you're creepy aren't you all right we
gotta find her um
if i was creepy baby ball doll
ah obvious it's obvious you went this
way
uh it's so obvious
[Music]
i found you [ __ ] you're terrible at
this
ow my fingers i don't have any legs
well my shadow looks so creepy
all right i guess i gotta find there
again okay this time
there's a video delay
how's that how does that work
maybe i'll restart a lot
okay so down up down up
down uh resent the lane
down up down up
seems to fix it some people say if you
refresh the stream in
it all right i gotta find her um
well again
it's a child i'm smarter
faster stronger
deadlier
what's so [ __ ] funny
i don't like this
tell me
oh ethan's poor hands dude
okay so i guess
there's a time anywhere
right in the brain do it again do it
again
honestly i would
okay where do we look now
this blood trail here
[Music]
nope
uh huh i will find you
come out come out wherever you are
are we getting closer no we just went in
circles oh [ __ ]
uh
upstairs again i found you
again yes
[Music]
oh
okay it's over
nice she became cold yes
yeah okay everything's right
that's that's a nice change of pace i
like that
good no more bing bang bang bang boom
boom
we combine it with a force wing key
so that's who's behind i don't think i
need any legs flask
okay fine i'll grab the lengthwise that
makes two
now would you let me leave thank you
that was easy that's the one that made
it flawlessly all right i made it easy
because children dumb
i'm hungry now what time is that
oh the button is there wait what
there
uh-huh okay
we're in elevator
i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
saying oh damn
thank you for that awkward moment you're
welcome hope you enjoyed as much as i
did let's get out of here
i need to fish that part
sucked i couldn't collect any items
what's the point
get the doll you can pick her up oh
no are you serious which doll
no you're joking you if you're [ __ ]
with me i'm gonna be so
mad nothing happens
oh what a shame i don't get to bring the
ugly doll
was that a thing i could sell ah
where was the doll i didn't see it you
mean the uh the doll next
ah that's a shame
oh well got myself back
oh well where are we now
benevientos treasure
oh [ __ ] could this be our time to use
our mind
hold up guys i've been waiting to use
this
yeah let's do
there we go oh something that would take
out two of them
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh this is going to be bad
oh you missed me
there's more jesus christ guys
thank you
i got an achievement for blowing many up
that's cool
i like that
can we finally check out the houses and
stuff nice
hey hey
oh what let's
go
proper military [ __ ] i like that
i like bad
okay
i want to remove the weapon charm
can i
come on i want the weapon charm back
oh no
shame
apparently i missed something in the
house where
this guys stop telling me stuff
if you don't know oh [ __ ]
we could try out the shotgun here but i
think
it's killing him
[Applause]
i'm gonna say my shotgun ammo
i can't go back guys
tell me earlier next time
uh spherical do we have that
uh
toilet gotta check it
photo of a strange bird i
always like collecting those
where'd he go
there it is oh so we gotta find where
that bird is probably
all right here we go as well
oh nice
get the doll now the real doll
yes cool uh
okay let's find out where that bird
photo is
is this the main courtyard
yeah i know where this is
why is there a safe spot here
so probably the the thing that goes in
the labyrinth puzzle is where the bird
is
okay let's go back then
we'll come back here
oh gosh
where are they going
we're fine apparently there was a goat
on the bridge
remember someone said it
there it is
nice
i don't know what that does but i did it
how many bridges do you need man [ __ ]
okay
through the creepy oh shish
[ __ ]
bird cage here
oh this is bad
i'll kill you all [ __ ]
what are you not dead
thank you
all right did i miss any hello
took care of that situation i'd say my
you can jump down here can't you i
remember
wait what the [ __ ]
oh okay nice
hello i got a doll for you this looks
familiar to you
all right i forgot the bird cage [ __ ]
i'll go back we're going back there
anyway
i've procured some new items for you mr
winters
nice now this is something to splurge on
splurge
now do we sell this shotgun that's the
real question
it's already better
worry not you can buy it back if you
like thank you
explosive rounds
uh greatly reduced recoil
no yeah you'll be slaughtering
[Music]
flash banks that's interesting
i'm skilled at all sorts of weapons
modifications and we'll do them for a
small fee
one moment please
hmm i gotta wait upgrading this kind of
stuff
this is combinable so we shouldn't sell
that
okay i want to know how to use explosive
rounds
[Music]
yeah an interesting selection and yes
they're quite cheap
and handgun i probably want to make as
good as possible
damn you're a thick boy
okay so if i remember the blue bird
thing was here
right it was here right yeah there's
that thing this tree
excuse me
you're supposed to be dead
[Applause]
god it's still tricky to aim man
come on just die
nice
i hear another one no they're just
becoming dust
okay are we dead
all right there you are what do i do
with it i shoot it
just bird hunting season
sorry bird
juicy game oh
nice oh we got some herbs
all that for some juicy game
i thought for sure it would be the
labyrinth puzzle thing
now i'm really annoyed i didn't get that
birdcage thing
should we go fishing on the lone road i
want to check it out honestly
hopefully no zombies on the way
going fishing mate
can i even i don't think i can
oh we could fit this now
no what get out of here
i was so excited
whoa there's so many
what is this hidden weapons
so we missed something big on here oh
i'm so mad
what i didn't did these show up before
that did not show up before i gotta
check this out now
is that what he updated on our map
okay first let's make sure
there's actually no way for me to go
back i mean it doesn't seem like it
but it's worth checking out okay we got
a bunch of bird cages there's usually
stuff in them
money that was another one
oh okay
i'll take it
oh i missed you baby
we missed a lot of stuff what the [ __ ]
just saying it's the guy running through
the woods with a knife no big deal
yeah duke after me i remember now
so there's the puzzle and there's a
oh we got a beast and we got a sleigh
hello where'd you kill
he's gonna attack me isn't he oh he's
dumb as [ __ ]
uh see if we can knack him come back
i just want to kill you oh we [ __ ] you
man
die i'm trying to mercy kill you
thank you
did i get it
birds
me
it's nice that they show it on the map
at least
i'll give him that
uh
maybe we can cook up some more meals now
[Music]
i'm so mad
oh wait the treasure is there
hmm okay
so we can't access the treasure i just
don't know how
you guys know which one you use
the wheel
key to lucas has a west side of the
village okay
huh
okay i don't think we have what we need
here yet
but that's good to know
wait there was a slab in the graveyard
where i got the blue bird
i'm just running back and forth here
like an idiot
so nothing has changed this whole
playthrough basically
oh another bird cage
nice
well we got a ton of stuff to collect on
the map now
as if we haven't collected stuff enough
sorry i don't mind it makes it fun
i also want to see if we can make the
recipe now
since we got the bird and the beast
yes cook me meal please
well then feel free to peruse
indeed we need four more poultry
okay we'll get that
or more poultry for the delicious snack
till next week
[Music]
let's see if that chat lied about the
slab
there's a slab here somewhere
they lied they're all a bunch of liars
come on
okay well ignoring that there's
treasures here
um they're locked houses this should be
okay to get
let's check it out
wait we have a shortcut in here now we
don't have to go all the way around
i said shorthand and then
why am i here
oh the crypt
oh oh
nice okay we'll we'll come back i don't
want to run back all the way again i'll
i'll go there later
for now i need to figure out how i get
there and this map is so
confusing
have we gone in here
no ah
nice
hey girl a teddy bear
is it lunch time yes pancakes
pancakes [ __ ]
well hope you guys enjoy
another epic episode i love the game
thanks for helping out
thanks for joining have a great day and
i'll see you tomorrow
bye bye hey
i'm so excited for pancakes